Abortion bans across the country
are making it even more difficult for women with cancer diagnosis
to get treatment and to survive their illnesses.
A 37 year old woman in Ohio was denied an abortion.
Her doctor said she needed to save her life
to continue treatment for her stage 3 melanoma.
Under Florida's abortion law,
terminal cancer patients will not get abortions
that they need to continue their treatment
because the abortion would not save their life,
it would only extend their life.
And Project 2025 even calls for the CDC
to track data on every pregnancy that is ended from a treatment
like chemotherapy. Attacks on a reproductive rights
are leaving women in an impossibly cruel situation
in an already devastating time in their lives.
Literally imagine being told you have to spend your dying days
carrying a pregnancy to term
instead of getting treatment that could extend or save your life.
Bringing a child into this world that you won't be around to parent,
or leaving children that you already have without a parent
because you can't get treatment.
We owe it to them
and to ourselves to vote to protect our reproductive rights.